avant de passer au sujet culture
j'accueille en plateau notre deuxième
invité nicolas milovanovic bonjour vous
avez été conservateur au château de
versailles pendant onze ans et il ya un
mois tout juste vous êtes devenu
conservateur en chef au musée du louvre
et vous venez de sortir ce livre
intitulé la princesse palatine je vais
le montrer voilà la princesse palatine
protectrice des animaux
c'est un peu le fruit de toutes vos
années de travail à versailles en fait
absolument alors je n'ai pas fait que ça
estime imagine mais ayant une passion
pour les animaux les chats doivent
embaucher un passionné de changer deux
chats d'ailleurs j'ai dédié le livre un
mais deux charmants qui s'appelle
attendaient en moyenne mimine lançait sa
mine et pardon min et y voilà touchant
les plus intelligents de versailles et
de sa région et donc du coup je me suis
amusé à étudier en fait la place
qu'avait les petits animaux de compagnie
en fait les chats les chiens les
perroquets les colombes à versailles
parce que c'est une histoire qui n'est
pas connu il n'y a pas de livre dessus
alors que verse a été rempli de vie en
fait
et ces petits animaux contribuer à la
vie versaillaise et donc si on veut
avoir une idée de versailles aujourd'hui
qui est plus vivant qui est plus proche
de la réalité
c'est très important de savoir quelle
place avec ses animaux en fait comme ça
on le doit un petit peu un petit peu
même beaucoup à la princesse palatine
alors qu'ils étaient 7 sept princesses
qui est aussi une duchesse je crois
d'orléans c'est absolument absolument
duchesse d'orléans fait c'est la belle
soeur de louis xiv donc c'est la
deuxième c'est ça c'est la devise
américaine c'est la deuxième épouse de
du frère de louis xiv on flippe
d'orléans donc elle épouse ans et 171
elle est d'origine allemande elle est la
fille de l'électeur palatin et donc
c'est une alliance politique bien
entendu et donc elle s'installe à
versailles au début des années 70 elle a
une place éminente en tant que belle
soeur du roi et elle va avoir une
passion pour les animaux et surtout elle
va écrire un nombre incroyable de la
train elle a écrit on estime aujourd'hui
qu'elle a écrits de son vivant soixante
mille lettres en fait combien par jour
ça ça fait plus de 10 par jour c'est
énorme c'est donc elle passait son temps
à écrire et donc c'est aujourd'hui une
des sources les plus précieuses pour la
connaissance de la vie quotidienne à
versailles parce que ce qu'elle écrivait
c'était ces journées elle décrivait ce
qu'elle faisait donc c'est aussi une
manière de connaître la vie réelle à
versailles au 17 et au xviiie siècle et
donc il se trouve que dans cette
correspondance les animaux reviennent
très souvent parce que les adore et là
on a beaucoup voilà el ahad est
habituellement plus de dix chiens quand
même pas mal elle a des préférences très
marqué pour certains à certaines races
donc elle préfère les espagnols
espagnols nous son petit n'a pu voir
alors sur lequel on a vu une petite
petite faute très petites photos en
temps tu sûr je vais arriver de la
princesse palatine qui posait avec son
ex compagne donc parce que évidemment
tous les courtisans et elle va en
premier lieu aimait se faire peindre
avec ces animaux préférés
c'est pourquoi les oui oui donc il ya
une iconographie étonnante des des
personnages de la cour pain avec leur
animal favori dans les bras mais aussi
des portraits des animaux eux mêmes avec
leur nom inscrit en lettres d'or
je représente 14,1 le beau frère de la
princesse palatine a fait faire le
portrait de ses chiens préférés et qui
existe toujours
ça c'est des choses aussi moins connu
c'est le livre a aussi pour but de mieux
faire connaître cette histoire des
animaux qui a donné lieu à des
chefs-d'oeuvre puisque des peintres très
renommés comme des portes ou de riz ont
peint les chiens du roi est donc là
c'est les chiens pose comme ça ils ont
leur nom en lettres d'or etc des
tableaux aujourd'hui conservée
tembo au louvre au musée de la chasse et
de la nature à paris à la mode à
l'époque de chiens on a pu voir les
bagnoles
oui alors il y avait des traces y avait
des carlins qui existe toujours
aujourd'hui c'est des tout petits chiens
venus de chine ou museau très plat c'est
très mignon c'est très joueurs voilà
exactement c'est ça hein car la foule
immense et donc ça c'était par exemple
les chiens que marie-antoinette adorait
lorsqu'elle arrive en france en 1770
donc pour épouser le futur lui 16
elle demande à ce qu'on lui envoie des
carlins est ce qu'on dit mops en
allemand et donc on a une lettre dont on
est certain qu'elle veut des carlins
parce que elle a besoin de son petit
univers beaucoup de chiens variante
honnête à vous voyez la princesse
palatine fait figure un peu de
précurseur à versailles par son amour
des animaux mais n'est pas la seule les
rênes suivante dans une usine ce cas
marie antoinette est aussi bien que les
rois l'ue-15 était un grand amoureux des
animaux mais alors justement la
princesse palatine qui est une
protectrice des animaux ce qu'elle avait
un rôle un peu avant gardiste vous ce
que finalement elle s'inscrivait
complètement dans son époque alors un
peu des deux mais elle avait quand même
un rôle de précurseur puisque à
versailles elle prenait la défense des
animaux
alors pourquoi le premier défense parce
que la théorie admise on l'a aujourd'hui
oubliée au xviie siècle c'est le
cartésianisme s'impose donc les théories
de descartes grand philosophe s'il en
est mais qui considérait que les animaux
étaient des machines c'est la fameuse
théorie des animaux machine donc pour
lui c'était sur deux rouages
d'horlogerie voyez donc du coup au monde
et niait toute sensibilité tout
sentiment aux animaux et la princesse
est vraiment opposés à cette théorie est
toujours avec humour parce que il faut
quand même dire et c'est très important
que c'était quelqu'un de très drôle
et est ce qu'il y a d'ailleurs valu bien
des déboires parce que
je sors un peu du sujet mais dans ces
lettres elle n'hésite pas à écrire de
madame de maintenon que c'est une jolie
ratatiner règle ses comptes
donc du coup ça le toit le roi lion
entier rigueur on hamm est extrêmement
de oui oui alors don à la fin du livre
on a un choix de lettres de la princesse
où elle parle des animaux donc pour
vraiment parce qu'en plus elle écrit
très bien et c'est un style très vivant
un très beau français d'ailleurs c'est
un des grands auteurs il ya même de
sévigné comme mon grand épistolier au
17e et on oublie souvent qui est aussi
la princesse palatine donc elisabeth
charlotte d'orléans et donc sur sa
défense des animaux elle dans une de ses
lettres dans plusieurs lettres en fait
elle prend vraiment leur défense elle
dit cette théorie est absurde cette
théorie de descartes est par exemple un
exemple c'est une discussion qu'elle a
avec un évêque cartésien et elle lui dit
mais
mais mes chiens sont au moins aussi
jaloux vous donc si vous vous êtes
jaloux si vous avez ce sentiment mes
chiens ont certainement aussi bardot on
peut dire ça on peut dire ça parce que
là vraiment cet amour des animaux et le
communiqué dans ces lettres et donc du
coup elles diffusèrent à versailles mais
dans toutes les cours européennes parce
que l'été en correspondance avec
beaucoup de personnes dans les courts
allemands notamment
et voilà donc c'est vrai qu'elle a
diffusé cet amour des animaux est fait
connaître la place des animaux à
versailles puisque on parlait de mende
effectivement il y avait une rivalité
des races et donc l'affirmait ses
préférences pour les espagnols contre
les carlingues
il ya des rasoirs ont disparu les
harlequins alors elle fait un commerce
si je puis dire d'arlequin allemande
cette race qui est exactement mais bon
là c'est une passion donc elle fait
partager sa passion et lcl elle donc
elle ou une race qui est très à la mode
à ce moment là on le sait par d'autres
sources
et c'est une race qui aujourd'hui
disparu et qu'on ne peut connaître que
par l'histoire naturelle de buffon une
planche de buffon qui montre ce qui
était un arlequin alors ça ressemblait
en fait ce qui sait si on veut vraiment
être scientifique c'est ça va vous
surprendre une sorte de dogue allemand
oui si un gigantesque mais vous le
miniaturisés et là vous avez un train de
15 en plus il faut les acheter le pelage
et la voilà alors c'est un animal les
dogues allemands miniature ça n'existe
plus aujourd'hui c'est existait à
l'époque et c'était très prisé alors à
qui s'adresse ce livre sera ma dernière
qu'elles sont savoir plutôt aux
passionnés d'histoire plutôt aux animaux
aux amoureux des animaux
tu peux pas les deux les deux les deux
c'est dire autre chose que se livrent
plaira à tous ceux qui aiment les
animaux
d'abord évidemment et puis versailles
l'histoire l'histoire ensuite donc ceux
qui aiment les animaux et l'histoire ils
trouveront leur bonheur dans ce livre
merci beaucoup
ah ben oui oui je les ai vus il est très
bien en tout cas merci beaucoup en tout
cas nicolas milovanovic